ha ha ha happy Halloween that's right
and to celebrate this spooky holiday
grand theft auto online treats us to
another festive update now so I'm told
these are all available until November
16 so gobble this shut up quick how do
we take a look visit your nearest hair
salon for 30 new spooky face paints to
choose from most of them are skull
themed with a few demons and all I will
go with this one next up to get monster
themed masks
that's a little ominous as I was saying
you head on down to the Vespucci mass
shop and choose plenty up well I guess I
was warned anyway juice from plenty of
scary masks such as the Red Skull burst
the bloody scalded psycho AKA Freddy
Krueger Lucifer or holla this red flayed
demon I love how he's all teeth hey
there kid you have any suntan lotion
check out Benny's motorworks that is if
you have the right modded up wit you can
choose one of 20 terrifying bobbleheads
I'll take the zombie Benny oh look at
that his eyes light up too great but if
you're not looking to invest into a
lowrider good news two new cars meet the
lurcher hearse which comes stocked with
a dark organ horn and a Frankenstein in
the caboose oh he loves to ride
and then there's Frank and strange
equipped with purple felt interior and a
bitchin engine it's quite the hot ride
ain't that right lady and then there's a
flashlight sick but where the flashlight
really comes in handy is with the new
adversary mode slasher it's a one v all
scenario you and your buddies hide in
the dark only equipped with a flashlight
who are you hiding from oh just this
dude with a shotgun as handy as the
flashlight is turn it on and you
basically give yourself away the team
hiding needs to last for three minutes
if the killer knocks off everyone except
the last man the last man automatically
gets a shotgun to take down the killer
it's a great mode so check it out if you
got a chance well that's it for me
everyone you have yourself a great
Halloween take care
I